yeah this is Pete peppers with candy
crush soda saga tips calm and this is a
level 90 walkthrough with some
commentary so I'm making this go along
with the guide and someone had mentioned
on the gamers unite board that I admin
that there were more bears now there's
32 I'm not sure where they added him but
the strategy hasn't changed and doesn't
seem any harder really but um since I
was right not the tips I was good I
figured I'd make one of these videos too
so I'm just just trying to make some
okay here's an important part you see
this is a bluefish over here so we need
to took freebie so if I hit a blue candy
that'll please look free the licorice on
the right hand side so that's so they
can get loose and that's really all I'm
doing right now is I'm trying to move
down as fast as I can and here I can
make a rat + a stripe that I'll hit that
stripe and get that out of there so I'm
just trying to move as fast as I can and
free these special candies along the way
and that set up really nice there I got
through that one fast and here I can get
this thing at this blue one this blue
stripe to come down you can see I could
have made another stripe but instead
what I did was just drop that so that I
could be sure to free the coloring candy
so now I have you know just to get
through the bears as fast as possible
and I still have 22 minutes which is
really kind
good a lot of times it feels like it
doesn't matter how many minutes you have
when you get out of here and you can
still get stuck in this room you can see
how thin it is in the middle it even
with everything going good in the
beginning you can get kind of stuck here
sometimes so try not to get too
frustrated I know I'm losing a couple I
was hoping I would bring those specials
down but they've they popped so I have
17 moves and this is why we have to free
those specials on the side because it
sets it up so that we can use them in
the shaft that on the left-hand side you
only have three bears left to get here
but again you can get kind of stuck in
this one too so well there's two fish so
that'll take out these three and they'll
give us 12 minutes in the last room
which is pretty good our other freed
specials are on the side they're waiting
for us and since they're both blue and
there's a lot of blue up there we'll
just go ahead and match them I guess if
there's like certain things set up with
different colors then you might want to
wait and keep in mind you see how they
kind of go in two waves this is a simple
move here we're definitely gonna match
these two together they kind of come
with two waves when you match them with
the color in candy so you can the more
of the color that you have on the board
the better and they're since they were
both blue you know we it'll it'll hit
the blue plus one other color and they
kind of get set off of a staggered
fashion alright so we have four bears
left in nine moves and there's a color
bomb we can make now those two on the
Left are pretty far over so we're gonna
want to try to set up a striped or fish
with this color bomb and
anyone think moves this could be kind of
hard to do you could just fire off the
blue and you could do it that way but I
like to set up the combos so I'll see if
I can make a striped here I don't know
if we'll be able to match that one
here's another one on the right side and
actually right above us right here we
can match the red and drop the blue down
and you can see there's two oranges up
in the top so hopefully those will all
come together so that we can drop this
drive yeah it will and with our lives
two moves we can match this and that
should clear them all out and it did so
you know this is the kind of level it
definitely takes a kid bored you won't
always move that fast but if you clear
those if you freeze and I should say if
you free this the trap special candies
on the side it gives you a way better
chance and I think it's the best
strategy I beat it without doing that
but it just takes them a whole lot of
luck so alright I hope you enjoyed the
video hope it helps visit our site candy
crush soda saga tips calm and we'll have
more videos soon thanks